Speaker 1: All right. One more Elon Musk's story
and the Elon Musk stuff is just getting worse
and worse and worse. Elon Musk tweeted
over the weekend. Oh, God. He tweeted,
quote, My pronouns are prosecute slash pouce.
This is basically two different things. One,
it's ridiculing and making fun of gender
pronouns, which is very, very big right now
on the right. One of the areas that most excites
and titillate is the right at this point in time
is being anti-trans. Anti-trans is just really
big on the right at this point in time. So Elon
Musk is sort of stoking that. And also Elon Musk
is stoking more violence against Dr. Fauci and his
wife and his family. Dr. Fauci needing security.
He's a doctor. He needs security because of the
amount of ire and targeting that has been done
of Dr. Fauci. So stoking unrest. Additionally,
by the way, that tweet from Elon Musk got a
million likes on Twitter. So for all of the
arguments that Twitter is a left wing cesspool,
the right wing stuff coming from people like Elon
Musk and others getting a lot of likes, a lot a
lot of likes. Another aspect to the crazy weekend
from Elon Musk is the following as reported by the
Street. Elon Musk threatens Twitter 2.0 employees.
The billionaire social media revamp efforts
are widely covered in the press. Elon Musk
likes to control the narrative. He has fired a
whole bunch of different people and now he is
threatening leakers, people who leak information
with lawsuits. That is what this article is about,
and I encourage you to check it out. Elon Musk
saying Twitter will immediately seek damages.
Twitter will immediately seek damages. Elon Musk
is threatening to sue Twitter employees who leak
confidential information to the press. He's asking
staffers to sign a pledge indicating they've
understood the letter, by the way. How wild is it
that the letter threatening people about leaking
has leaked, as evidenced by the many detailed
leaks of confidential Twitter information? A
few people at our company continue to act in
a manner contrary to the company's interests
and in violation of their NDA. This will be said
only once if you clearly and deliberately violate
the NDA that you signed. When you joined, you
accept liability to the full extent of the law,
and Twitter will immediately seek damages. So
it is more and more and more of this exact same
stuff that we started seeing before Elon
Musk even purchased Twitter. Of course,
those on the right, including like on Fox News,
they find it all hilarious. Here's Dagen McDowell
commenting on the humor of Prosecute FAUCI.
Speaker 2: But John Brennan was at it again over
the weekend. You know, Elon Musk was going after
Fauci and, you know, his regular hilarious way.
Speaker 1: Yes. Prosecute Fauci is just really,
really funny. A doctor with decades of service who
is trying to deal with or has had been trying
to deal with a pandemic, a global pandemic.
He needs to be targeted in Elon Musk's humorous
way. These folks are very dangerous. And at this
point, it's really clear that what Elon Musk
wants to do is to promulgate and perpetuate
right wing disinformation and the shilling for
that type of that type of content on Twitter.
What his underlying motivation is, I don't
really know. And it's speculative. Is it that he
genuinely has political views that he believes are
best served by fomenting right wing disinformation
on Twitter? Maybe. Maybe that's what it is.
Is there some personal financial angle that he
believes would be served by turning Twitter into
some kind of right wing disinformation chamber?
Maybe that's the case. Could it be that he is
working in concert with I don't even know who and
that all together they've decided, let's destroy
Twitter from the INS? I don't believe we know
yet. I believe it's premature to explain exactly
what it is that is motivating all of this, but it
is getting very, very bad. And I don't believe
it's going to turn around any time soon. We'll
have all of these clips on our Instagram, which
you can find at David Pakman show on Instagram.